Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier
and welcome to "The Stranger"
I'm not gonna pretend like I know a goddamn thing about this game.
because I have absolutely no idea,
And why is rain going up....?
Okay, anyway, like I said, don't know anything about this game,
Highl- hello...
Why am I in the game with the Illuminati
Hi
[Onscreen text] "Ugh... Another one."
"Let me guess--"
"You are here to find treasure or some nonsense like that."
"Guess what?"
"No treasure in this place."
"Not even a dime."
"Might as well just lay down and go back to sleep."
"Skulking squatters..."
"They call me 'Headwall'."
I call you "Illuminat-o"
[Onscreen text] "Consider this my warm welcome."
Okay...
W-okay, goodbye!
Well, we are off to a riotous start
I have no idea what I am doing
and I'm just as confused as when I started this.
But supposedly,
Yada yada yada
highly rated so
hence why I'm playing it.
Ah!
Oh!
Okay...
A little confused, but it's beautiful!
Reminds me of Wind Waker
Oh, hi
Hello?
Please tell me you're a squirrel,
because I think I'm king of you.
[Onscreen text] "Hey you, yeah you with the weird"--
Hey!
Don't make fun of my bulbously huge head!
I know I have an enormous head
don't worry about it!
[Onscreen text] "You think you're big enough to roll with the bone squad?"
I can make many a bone joke,
but my brain just ain't up to it right now.
[Onscreen text] "Who's the bone squad? Well... er..."
"I'm in it, I can tell you that much."
"And you can be too! Provided you can show me how you hold up in the paint!"
"Make me proud, Jammers! Er..."
Maybe I'll-- "I'll think of a better nickname later, after you're officially 'in'."
"Here's a ball. Don't lose it! It's our last one."
Okay!
I'm a little con- what the hell just happened?
Whe- Oh!
Hey, oh God.
[Onscreen text] "Extra Plus Ball, not for use by humans or animals"
[yell of exertion]
Oh, that didn't work!
Oh God.
[Onscreen text] "Bone vaguely familiar"
Ahhhh!
Come back here!
Okay
Anyway, this has gone horribly awry.
Ahh... too much power.
Habooski!
Shit.
It's more like a beachball or a kickball than an actual basketball.
Okay, here we go.
[scatting]
Mmm, shabooski!
Oh!!!
That didn't go in!
[Onscreen text] "Eh...close enough."
Thanks, man.
[Onscreen text] "Meet me upstairs we gotta discuss your initiation."
Well, I don't even know if I want to be part of this club!
I literally just walked into this island from a cave
that I apparently teleported into
and I'm apparently dreaming.
I have no understanding of anything that is going on or why I'm here.
But yeah, sure, I wanna join your "Bone Club".
But first, I'm gonna get this in here.
'Cause I'm a winner!
I'm not a quitter, I'm a winner, I'm a-
[singing] Heyyyy!
YEAH!
Man, I could've just gotten that in if I got another try.
Gave up before I got there.
And why is this bone familiar to me?
Why would this bone be vaguely familiar?
And also, what's going on in the background over there?
I'm so- I've- [laugh]
I thought I had questioned reality just a little bit too much
and it decided to all collapse on me but
y'know what, I'm just gonna stop lollygagging and actually try to get up here.
[funny exertion noise]
[different funny exertion noise]
[Onscreen text] "Some items you can interact with after pressing E again"
"Decorative Urn"
"It's pulsing with dead life. Maybe we should rub it"
[urn squeaking]
[continues squeaking]
[fart noise]
I rubbed the shit out of that
Oh!
Hi, hello
[Onscreen text] "BOO! did I getcha'? you look pale"
"Don't worry about it... happens all the time"
Ok. Who are you? Do you have a name?
Oh, ok, you´re just gonna
ALRIGHTY THEN!
You know what I'm just gonna go along my way
The disturbing penis ghost
Over here can just haunt that little realm of reality
while I try to join the Bone Squad
Is i-[Laughs] is this just like, uh, like a game interpretation of an actual dream
Because this is awesome!
Like every part of this is amazing!
[Onscreen text] "ALRIGHT!"
"You knocked that one right out of the park!"
"I mean, that was a real touchdown"
"You're a real Gretzky!"
"In fact, that's your nickname from now on."
"GRETZKY!"
Ok.
[Onscreen text] "Until I get bored of it or think of a better one."
"Welcome to the Bone Squad"
Is this like the...? Is this like..? What was it called?
Is this like the Bonercast?
That radio show that we talk about all the time?
Our personalized podcast talking all about boners all day all long?
All night?
All lon- all long boners all day, all night, all long?
Here at...Bonercast!
That wasn't the name of it.
Yeah! It was the name of it, why am I questioning myself?
I just looked it up. It was the Bonercast! Welcome to the Bonercast!
Tell us about your boner!
No? Ok, alright then, sorry.
[Onscreen text] "As a member you get full access to the island."
"Don't let any grumpy, floating, older than time"
"guardians of mystic whatever tell you otherwise."
"Say... Speaking of which, I've got something wicked awesome to show you!"
"It's on the other side of the island"
"A bit of a trek but totally worth it"
"Why don't you get going and I'll meet you there?"
"I've got...squirrel stuff."
Hey! You are a squirrel! Hey!
I'm the king of that thing that you is!
"See you soon Gretzky! No... Martha Stewart! No... Obama?
Okay...
Alright, once you decide what you're going to talk about I'll come back to you
Whoa...
[crystal buzzes]
[Mark makes alarmed noise]
Well I did a thing there, holy shit
Who knew that I had such power?
Is that because I'm part of the boner squad?
The Bonercast? Or the Bone Squad?
I'm gonna call it the Boner Squad
It's me! President Obama!
This is my Obama impression here to...
Oh!
Okay!
Alright then, Obama going up the hill now.
Don't know why I'm here or where.
Man, this is beautiful
Also, that music is pulsating and funky
Hello~
Can you come back down here for Obama?
Thank you!
Where the hell am I going?
Well I can run...
Yeah, this game is so weird I found it on...
I found it on Game Jolt but it came out last year but I just oh....
[Onscreen text] "A Tiny, Perfect Obelisk. It's so tiny, it's so perfect!"
It's tiny obelisk Oooooscar!
It's, it's, it's oblong oblo...it's Oblong Obelisk Oscar!
Alright, good job being an obelisk I'm gonna put you down now.
Hey Obama has the power!
Ha boo boo!
I'm gonna make it! I'm gonna make it! I'm gonna make it!
I'm not gonna make it, Obama's not gonna make it.
It's a good thing I've got this obelisk here.
[funny noises of effort]
Ok, alright. I got it.
Cooool, still don't know why I'm here.
But Obama's going to keep pressing on.
What happened to my obelisk?
What happened to my...? I had an obelisk!
I didn't know what to do with it but I had it.
And I'm gonna go back
Can I go back? Ok, I can go back
That obelisk better be there.
OH!
God tit my nipples! Goddammit!
That didn't make any sense at all why was I teleported all the way back here?
I didn't wanna do this again!
What a load of assitry! Alright I'll be back, apparently [grumbles]
What the...?
Oh! You dick titting fucker-nut!
You sack of shit bags!
What is the...? Did I...? I broke it!
I broke the goddamn game didn't I?
Oh I fucking broke it hard!
I broke...it
Herp-derp-a derpy-derp
[singing] Don't know what the fuck to dooo!
[speaking again] Oh there we go!
Now it's gonna...well shitty dicks
Ohhhh, noooo! There we...[cuts off]
Ok this time I'm not going to be a bag of asses
and I'm gonna get...Oblong Obelisk Oscar
and do a thing.
Ok, so does this belong anywh...
[splash]
Well alright, at least that corrects my mistakes for me
Does this go anywhere?
Hellooo-oo?
Glug glug bitch!
Alright then...
I guess it doesn't go anywhere.
Then why'd I get a tiny obelisk?
Okey-dokey then!
So I'm just gonna take this, I guess this was nothing
This was a whole lot of nothing
I looked around, I can't go in the waw-waw
I have to just keep pressing forward. Ok, I can do that.
Hey buddy!
Heeey buddy! This looks weird and
you're probably going to make me worship something or someone.
Hello!
[Onscreen text] "Hey Air Jordan!"
Thanks man!
"How's it going?"
Oh pretty, pretty nice.
"So I gotta admit, I have like no clue where that spot"
"I was looking for was."
"I thought I had it, but then I lost it."
"But we can still chill right?"
"Let's chilax until the dogs come home."
Talk about each other's boners!
"You don't seem super interested in that..."
"[sigh] maybe we can still find the spot then."
"It was somewhere around here, maybe if we just look around?"
Y-you're telling me you didn't look around
I mean, I found an obelisk before but I don't know what that was
in regards to so I'm just going to carry on and assume that I know
what is going on in this beautiful landscape of horrors.
Because like most games I'm going to assume that this
is all going to turn dark in some point in time
and I'm gonna die.
Oh!
Yeah, probably in there!
Oh! I have a funny feeling I gotta step into that thing's mouth
Which is usually pleasant but in this circumstance
I'm going to assume that it's bad for me
Ooh! What about over here?
Looks like a secret path into something!
Hello? Oh shit, please don't teleport me back.
Ah good, hellooooo!
[Onscreen text] "Hmm"
"Usually this thing here is all glowy"
"but as soon as you showed up it shut down."
"Maybe you have a disease?"
"Whatever it is we can't get anywhere here unless this thing is all lit up"
"You probably gotta go somewhere else and get blessed or whatever..."
Oh!
OH!
So this is the point in the story where I gotta go sacrifice
a virgin or whatever and then come back here coated
in the blood of a goat
So I'm gonna do those exact things you can't talk me
out of it I'm on my way I got the goat I got the virgin right here!
Uh, alright. What do I do ?
I gotta go get blessed?
Ah! Papa bless me!
Papa!
Alright, fine.
[singing]
This isn't the same place I came out of is it?
Oh maybe it is. Hello! Who the fuck are you?
[sing-song] Hiii!
[Onscreen text] "Hello, ok yes. Hi. Yes ok. You are not from here right?"
"You smell like away places, far, and maybe bagels."
"You on some big time quest for silks and spices, friend?"
"Not much of that stuff around here, mostly just dirt and squirrels."
"I used to know a friend like you, Snuff."
"Big ol' buddy. Big as me, even."
"He wasn't scared of the dark though."
"He made me a night-light with magic, probably"
"Big ol' Snuff went missing some mad fortnights ago, friend."
"Got lost in some mad mojos, soakin' in the dark spots I think."
"He was a nice guy."
"Just be careful when you're soaking with the mojos, ok?"
"They can't get you silks and spices, friend."
"Just bad directions."
Wait, are you talking about this magical squirrel
that's telling me to go get blessed in the blood of a virgin and a goat?
Possibly a virgin goat?
I'm not entirely sure about the circumstances
but I'm going to do that anyway because I don't trust you
[muttering] Actually I absolutely trust that guy, he seems amazing
[normal volume] OkI gotta admit
now that I've actually had a chance to wrap my head
around what the hell is going on here this game is legitimately cool
It's super well made, this game is free by the way.
It's just kind of a trip here.
It makes good use of its visuals and limited, ya'know, resources
and what not. Why is this here?
Why is there a bowling pin?
Why is there a bowling pin!?
Hello!
[Onscreen text] "Hello sweetpea! Doin' a little adventuring and exploring eh?"
"You're really taking this looking around thing to heart."
"You could get a lot higher if you had a grappling hook or stilts."
"Or legs made of springs or like a majestic gecko steed."
"His name is Sunshine."
I'm beginning to think you're crazy and I should probably
keep away from you.
I don't think you want to get me a grappling hook
I think you wanna get me dead
and then probably steal my soul.
Oh we...oh where am I now?
I don't know where I am. Oh!
[southern accent] Oh my goodness!
What is this now?
[normal voice] Hellooo?
I've come here for your spices and to possibly get blessed.
What is that? Do I want that? It looks like I want that.
It's a disembodied hand!
Oh no, it's a glove!
Yaaaay, I got a hook shot!
Oh man!
Is that you Foxy?
Foxy?
[Onscreen text] [strained] "Second...time...this...week"
[normal voice] Ok...
Sorry about that friend.
Well I'm going to take your robotic arm
and I'm gonna use it to my own personal advantage.
How do I get out of this pit?
Oh, it's a teaching thing!
Oh it's an educationamal
How do I...? Do I have it equipped? I'm not learning hard enough.
There we go!
Ok, I don't think I was suppose to do that
I think I was supposed to learn how to hook.
But it did not happen...
Oh yes I was! Ok!
[Onscreen text] "Hey nice gizmo!"
Hey nice creeping around the corner like that you freaking weirdo.
"Look at you being all gangster stealing from the dead like that."
He wasn't dead he was talking to me don't worry about it.
"That robot will probably miss his arm in the afterlife."
"Whatever though, looks way cool."
"Mind if I give it a spin?"
"Huh? Ok, mob rule, finders keepers."
"See you later homeslice!"
I don't like you! You seem weird and creepy
and probably trying to kill me like I said.
God, I love this music!
I love the environment.
I love not knowing what the hell is going on!
[imitating banjo]
Why is there a keyboard here?
[pressing key repeatedly]
Hell yeah!
Hell yeah.
Ha!
Oh, I shouldn't have done that.
Spot a jump mid-jump, ok.
Eh!
Hooiiii!
Nice!
[more emphatically] Nice!
Oh that's cool!
[laughs] That's cool!
Ha!
Oh that's so cool!
That's so cool the mechanics of this game are actually well thought out!
This game is just free, it's so cool!
Hiiii-ohhh silver!
Alright where the hell am I going now?
Hello?
God! I just seem to be traversing nothingness!
Also what was that about getting blessed?
I'm back here now! Oh good!
Oh wheres the...I see a target over there, oh yes!
Oh yes!
[nervous sounds of exertion]
Ok.
Now we're up here...Oh that's so cool!
That's neato!
That's neato ka-beato! That' so sick!
I'm trying to use new lingo besides "cool"
but I don't think it's working for me.
But either way...trying.
Oh hello! Are you gonna bless me?
Ah ka-blaaaam!
[rumbling and dramatic music]
Oh shit!
I feel blessed!
Have I been blessed?
I'm going to assume the answer is yes judging by the music and the smoke.
Alright then I'm out of here! I got blessed little buddy!
I don't nee..Woah! Hey!
That's a little disturbing. Hey, how ya doin'?
[Onscreen text] "Just a bunch of pretty lights, right?"
"Tourists!"
"Waltzing in and messing with our delicate mess."
"Walking all over the grass, realizing cosmic energy"
"It's just mystic pollution you know?"
"Ugh. I'm the guardian of the wrong mountain."
"Just a bunch of boring camera flashers here."
"Fish can swim as long as they like, but they have gills, you do not."
"Stop before you've gone too far."
Ok...
Don't know what any of that mea...
[interrupting][Onscreen text] "Did that fish line make sense?"
"I've been working on my metaphors"
Yeah I think I kinda get what you mean
but I'm just gonna carry on anywa...
Heeeeyyyy! Ahh, missed my target.
But I think I'm blessed now
so I can probably go back to the other side
and do a thing-a-ring and bout the mystic bling-a-ling
Do you have anything?
"Hello!"
[interrupts] Oh no no no, ok goodbye.
Sorry about your loss!
And I'll be with you in a second. Wait, you weren't here before.
[squirrel chitters]
[Onscreen text] "This thing here. This 'face' if you will"
"It opens, I remember that much."
"But I really can't help you much more than that buddy."
Alright well I- I got blessed so I'm gonna go over here
I'm gonna use my blessings. Got my fresh coat of blood.
Ready to rock!
Hello? Is it glowing? Yes! It seems to be glowing.
[Onscreen text] "There we go! Look at this shiny thing!"
"Step on up and feeeeel the magic."
Y'know, I hear that line before
but, uh, it didn't turn out too well for me but I'm gonna trust you this time.
Press space...to activate it.
Whoooaaa! Holy shit! Ok.
Wow!
I made my target!
[shriek]
Habooski!
Alrighty then!
Shibi-da-booski!
Where am I now?
Why am I in the mixture of Stonehenge and the....
those islands with the head...things?
That I don't know what they are but they got heads
Oh! Bless me!
Papa bless indeed! Papa will bless you!
Oh hi! Good you're here again.
[Onscreen text] "You have ignited the second statue."
"Do you know what any of this means?"
"Do you know where you're going?"
"What you're feeling?"
"You do not, do you?"
No I do not.
"You're messing with stuff way out of your league buddy!"
"I feel like I should be making that as clear as possible"
Nah not really I'm not getting any of it.
[sigh] "I'm too old for this."
Alright then.
You take your age and go somewhere else with it
'cause I guess I got what I needed and I'm gonna carry on.
So goodbye! Is the mouth open now?
Is it time to step inside mouth?
Hmmm
Not quite there.
[Onscreen text] "What you been up to? This place has been making"
"all kinds of wild noise."
"I think whatever you're doing is really screwing everything up."
"...So why stop now?"
"I still don't know how to get this open"
"but something around here has started making a tone of racket."
"Maybe you could find a way to shut it up so we could talk easier?"
Yeah, that's probably a primary concern here.
Hey you! Bless me, touch me
I don't know, do something to me!
I'm ready to go. Maybe something up there?
I wish there was a shortcut for my grappling hook
I sure am tired of walking all this way.
Ohhh, hello!
Habooski!
Open sesame!
Hi there!
I did it!
[Onscreen text] "Wow, cool!"
"Did you do that?"
"Neat."
"Anyway, there's a shortcut right through here"
"I just remembered."
"So neat coincidence you opened this right when I remembered."
"Wanna head through?"
You know what?
It's intimidating but you know what
I'm a brave boy, I'm gonna go for it.
I don't know why I'm here and I don't know why
I'm walking into a big face but I'm ok with all of this.
Everything here is cool.
What is this?
Oh I love the music!
Love the music! Ah ha, see you up there.
I can't get to you but you know
I'm gonna try!
There's gotta be a way to get up here.
The bridge already seems to be broken
so there's gotta be a way to habooski my way on up
Hm, ah! What's over here?
Can I build a bridge? Ohhh I don't think I went  the right way.
No I did not go the right way ok goodbyeee
Alright so there's got to be something else over here.
There's a tree
There's a door
There's a this, there's a that
There's a this maybe I can get up this [grunt]
Habidi babidi babidi bowww almost made it.
Oooh geez, almost made that.
There's something back here...?
Oh hey! A high-dee-high-dee-high-dee-ho!
Oh woom!
Ohhh, ok!
Barely made that.
That can get me somewhere else...?
Ah yes, more runes.
Yes please!
Habooski! Wah, that's not what I though that was going to be.
Hah, should I touch this?
I also see a USB stick. 56 megs? That's nothing!
Alright fine then. I can't make that jump.
But there's...
Oh!
Ahh, I see you, ok.
I'm gonna do that before I go pressing buttons that I don't know what do.
Hopefully this is going to get me somewhere I need to go.
Awaaay, ok oh geez
Oh!
[alarmed shouting]
Ok.
Hello.
Hi
Should I be here?
Tell me how I shouldn't be here. I am stuck
No! Don't push me off.
What is that?
"Mysterious stone object"
Ok
Alright
Hello!
Gah! I keep skittering around on this I'm just really unstable right now.
[Onscreen text] "You have made it this far do you expect applause?"
"Do you know how long it will take to close that mouth?"
"You should have heeded my advice."
"Your foolish determination to push forward will not get you any sort of reward."
"A wise man once said"
"'No! Stop! Don't!'"
"Maybe you will end up a blueberry too."
"I would like that."
Why did he end up a blueberry?
I'm gonna take my mysterious stone object
and fuck right out of here and you can just eat 10 dicks.
Alrighty then I'm gonna press this mysterious button.
Habooski!
Alright cool, I got this I'm gonna take this with me.
Goodbye everybody! Goodbye!
Where am I now?
Why am I here?
Oh!
This seems a lot more sacrificial than I would have liked
[Onscreen text] "Bjoremules liquid energy: Holy swang that's a lot of fuel"
Okey dokey then.
Still doesn't help me.
Alright I'm gonna jump on this thing
Ha-bem-brum-booski!
How about this thing too? Ha-brem-booski!
Alrighty then, where am I now?
Hey, are you a thing?
[Onscreen text] "Headwall's Favourite Meteor: Sure would be a shame if it got thrown into a volcano"
I completely agree! That guy's a douuuuche!
Boink!
[mischevious giggle]
Nice, it's gone foever!
Screw that guy, right?
Right? That's what I'm suppose to do. I mean not literally
Whyyy did I gooo...?
Hello!
Alrightly then.
Hahh! Whooo!
Ok, glad I go this stolen robot arm.
Is there anything else here?
Don't look like it!
Oh god that's disorienting.
But I seem to be making progress
which is good I suppose.
I mean I've destroyed a lot of probably priceless artifacts along the way.
Hey! Oh! You taking a lava bath there?
[Onscreen text] "Seriously?"
"I'm in the bath."
Whoa
What...wh..it's...
[stammering]
I'm a little confused.Ok goodbyeee!
Have a good...bath?
Ok
Hey look! A button!
Oh cool!
I can, I can zipline down? How do I...?
I don't trust this!
Ahhh shit
Ah no. Wahhh-booski, ok.
Habooski.
[scream]
Uh oh.
[relieved grunt]
It's very scary you know
trusting things like that.
We just gotta assume the game programmer PROGRAMMED IT RIGHT!
Oooh
[sigh]
That was a little too close for comfort.
Ok. Oh look! Another bowling pin!
[Onscreen text] "A few more of these and I can learn how to juggle"
That's what you said but I'm gonna throw it in the lava pit.
Because I'm an asshole apparently.
Alright.
Arrrm-burr-doosk!
Ok
Ha-bum-burr-bum
Okey dokey then!
Still disorienting, still weird
but I seem to be doing ok.
Ha!
Habooski!
Heeey!
Ok. Can I...? Is this not a...? Is...? Oh there we go.
Habooski!
Where am I? Where am I? Where am I?
[sounds of exertion]
Ok!
Let's do this!
Leeroy!
[humming]
Jenkins!
Habooski!
Alrigh then.
Haaaa booom
Alright
I wonder if subjecting myself to the probably constant barrage
of radiation that these things are
causing my body to endure is going to be good for me in the long run
Whee, oh cool!
Oh wait!
I don't know if that was correct this seems baaaaad!
Oh!
[scream]
What's happening?
I'm being shot out of a volcano!
Whoa!
[rumbling]
Whooo hooo!
Uhhh...
How did I get boarded up already exactly? Okay, whatever, I'm not going to question it.
[gasp] Hello!
What the fuck was that?
[squirrel chitters]
Well I guess...things are just...
I guess dialogue's just gonna be broke now I have no idea
I guess...
What? I've no idea...You can't break like that!
What?
Not right at the end when I have to find out what the story is!
What...What do you say?
All I hear is just "stop" is that suppose to happen?
I've no idea!
Hello!
Ok!
I'm disconcerted. Ah shit, that wasn't suppose to happen. Well...
Oops.
Ok, I wasn't supposed to go here.
I have really...
[pulsing beat]
I have no diea what the fuck...
[beat continues]
[beat cuts off]
Oh!
Hi!
Uhhh...
Oh.
[stuttering] Th-thank you?
I guess I'm just dead they kicked me into the ocean.
Great, am I a blueberry now?
Am I still a part of the Boner Squad
Fuck happened?
Ok anyway. That as a trip.
Holy shit, that was awesome!
I have no idea what happened and I'm already having fun!
Well then that was The Stranger I guess.
I'm going to wait to the end of the credits to see if there's anything over there but....
Ooh wow!
We done here?
Is that it?
Is that all she wrote?
Am I free to go?
Why did they throw me int the ocean?
Was there an alternate ending? I do not know.
But either way I guess, that is The Stranger
[end music starts softly]
What it seemed to me was it looked like a student project.
And sometimes those get a little weird
but this was weird in a lot of  very good ways.
And I imagine there a a lot of things Idid not fully explore
So if you wanna play for yourself I'll put a link in the description there below.
Thanks again everybody for watching. And as always I will see you in the next video. Buh bye!
[end music plays]
[boop]